[Musique]
Monsieur Éric Fidol, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Je vous interview aujourd'hui pour un
site internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
J'aurais aimé avoir votre qualité
d'expertise sur les récentes fuites de
Prisme, sur les fuites que différents
entreprises, différents organismes
organisent ou laissent faire. Qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez ?
Ah, c'est un vaste débat en fait. Prisme
d'abord, ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que
c'est que c'est pas la la comment
s'appelle la première euh le premier
cas. En fait, Prisme, c'est juste un
sous-programme particulier d'un plan
plus général.
Autrefois, ça s'appelait, ça s'inscrit
d'ailleurs dans le un programme que l'on
connaî qui s'appelle les Gelon euh qui
dont un des sous-programmes était euh
carnivore. Ouais, il faut savoir que le
contrôle de technologies passe par le
contrôle des acteurs qui mettent en
œuvre ces technologies. Donc c'est même
plus fort que ça. C'est pas que c'est
les sociétés qui ont été incriminées et
d'ailleurs il manque certaines sociétés
euh et laisser fuiter ou et laisser
sortir des données. C'est tout
simplement c'est une obligation de pour
les sociétés américaines de travailler
avec l'État et en particulier les
services de renseignement américain.
C'est c'est un autre monde he c'est pas
c'est très de la vision européenne mais
c'est une obligation. D'abord, on oublie
que il y a cette obligation, elle vient
du patriot
qui est une loi qui est certes a été
créée par Bush Junior, mais dont les
derniers les plus récents développements
ont été signés et validés par Obama.
D'où l'embarras de l'administration
actuelle, c'est que elle ne pouvait ne
pas savoir.
Ce sont des plans concertés, organisés
pour le contrôle des technologies.
Quelles sont les les répercussions pour
le citoyen français ? Ah bah pour le
citoyen français, pour les le citoyen
européen, je dirais bah c'est simple,
c'est que je dirais que sont peut-être
préoccupantes pour le citoyen lambda,
elles le sont plus pour les entreprises
françaises. Dès lors qu'on utilise un
service comme Facebook, comme qu'on
utilise Google comme moteur de
recherche, qu'on utilise un système
d'exploitation bien connu, qu'on utilise
un iPhone. De toute façon, les données
que l'on met dedans et encore une fois,
il y a pas que des données personnelles,
il y a aussi des données d'entreprise.
Ces données, il faut considérer qu'elles
sont lu à livre ouvert.
Vous parlez de Facebook, qu'est-ce que
vous avez découvert sur Facebook ?
Quelles sont les répercussions de
Facebook sur la vie privée des gens ?
Plus en détail.
Alors déjà d'un point de vue général,
faut savoir que Facebook, je trouve que
c'est un un
un superbe succès. On a réussi à faire
la plus grande agence de renseignement
privé au monde.
Ça c'est quand même prodigieux. Et où
les gens liquent leurs propres données
volontairement. Donc déjà ça c'est
génial. Mais c'est vrai, on a découvert
un nombre de choses, on n pas tout
découvert, c'est que euh on en partie
dans le domaine de la téléphonie mobile,
quand on se connecte sur Facebook,
l'application Facebook
récupère des à l'insu de l'utilisateur
des tas de données qu'elles dissimulent
sur téléphone. Alors, elle les dissimule
pas tant que ça parce qu'elles ne sont
pas chiffrées, mais elles sont stockées.
En gros, l'application Facebook sur
Android se comporte comme une véritable
éponge. On sait des d'autres hackers
l'ont révélé que quand Facebook prétend
vous confirmer qu'il a bien effacé vos
données, en réalité ces données sont
toujours présentes. Il y a une petite
expérience simple à faire. Supprimer
votre profil Facebook, supprimer votre
compte Facebook, il suffit d'aller sur
une bannière de connexion, de remettre
les anciens identifiants et comme par
magie, votre page réapparaît. Ça veut
dire que tout est stocké. Tout est
stocké. On stock pas les choses sans
but. En réalité, c'est il faut voir
Facebook comme une la plus gigantesque
euh je veux dire organisme de de
renseignement qui jamais été faite.
C'est la stasie à la puissance ce que
l'on veut.
Qui qui en France, quel organisme en
France peut protéger les gens ? Qui peut
protéger les entreprises ? Quelles sont
les dispositions entreprises par l'État
français pour nous protéger entreprise
et nous protéger citoyen ? Alors,
normalement, on a euh l'ACNI, la
Commission nationale informatique et
liberté. Le problème, c'est qu'elle n'a
pas ses pouvoirs sont limités et sont de
plus en plus rogé, notamment par les
dispositions de l'Organisation mondiale
du commerce, par le lobbing extrêmement
intensif et multinational qui font qu'il
est de plus en plus euh difficile pour
la la CLI et les organismes similaires
en Europe de bah de mettre ces grandes
compagnies au pas. On a vu toute la
difficulté qu'il y a qu'il y a eu euh
pour contraindre Google à modifier
notamment les règles soi-disant de
protection de la vie privée. Les
Allemands étaient moins inefficaces que
les Français. C'est un problème de moyen
mais aussi de volonté politique. Euh
alors après euh la protection ben c'est
pas un problème technique. Déjà on est
libre de ne pas utiliser d'utiliser
Facebook ou pas. Donc je pense qu'il y a
un problème d'éducation. il y a un
problème de rendre les utilisateurs
comment s'appelle conscients des
risques.
Mais je pense qu'il y a aussi un rôle
des politique d'interdire certaines
pratiques et de d'obliger à certaines à
certaines dispositifs de sécurité. Alors
en fait le problème plus général c'est
quand on est dans une entreprise le
problème n'est pas tellement la
technologie, c'est le droit dont elle
dépend. Il y a une différence
fondamentale en droit européen et
français euh pour lequel ben les données
que l'on confié un prestataire vous
continuent d'être votre propriété. Ça
veut dire que le prestataire a une
obligation ou à minimal moyen pour
protéger vos données. Alors qu'en gros
anglo-saxon, les données appartiennent à
ceux qui les traitent. Alors, un
journaliste dont j'ai oublié le nom
avait une formule subtile. Chez Google,
le produit c'est vous.
Donc dès lors que vous soumettez vos
données, elles lui appartiennent, il est
libre d'en faire ce qu'il veut, de les
donner à qui il veut, de les exploiter
commercialement. Et ça c'est une
différence fondamentale. Donc dirait que
la première règle pour une entreprise,
c'est d'ailleurs de regarder
parmi les différents prestataires qui
s'ofr qui s'offrent à elle, de regarder
de quel droit ce prestataire ou cette
compagnie dépend. Alors, c'est difficile
parce que quand on est une
multinationale, une grande société
française, ben faut regarder si par
exemple le capital il y a pas des fonds
de pension américain, si la société bien
dépend bien de droit français, ça
devient de plus en plus complexe. Et
c'est pour ça que je conseilleraiis à
des aux sociétés PME, PMI de favoriser
plutôt une offre, on parle beaucoup du
cloud ou ou du de l'hébergement
externalisé, bah de prendre plutôt des
petits des acteurs régionaux qui vont
offrir une garantie euh quant au aux
dispositions de sécurité prises sur les
données que qui leur sont confiées.
Vous avez parlé des politiques, des
législateurs.
Euh qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
sur leur formation ? Sont-ils prêts ?
sont-ils suffisamment formés pour
appréhender correctement les risques que
le numérique comporte ? Est-ce que vous
pensez que ces mêmes législateurs
sont trop soumis à des groupes de
pression ? Est-ce que ces législateurs
sont tout à fait intègres ? Est-ce que
c'est est-ce que les législateurs
vont dans le sens de l'intérêt général ?
cette question en fait, il y a plusieurs
aspects. D'abord, il faut savoir que de
par en France en tout cas, la formation
des hommes politiques est inadaptée à
l'évolution du monde technologique. Nous
avons des gens qui ont fait souvent le
ce qu'on appelle leur humanité. Ça c'est
une formation plus droit, histoire du
droit éventuellement pour les les moins
littéraires économique mais on a on se
retrouve en situation où nous avons des
décideurs qui ne comprennent plus rien à
la technologie et qui prennent des
décisions malheureusement qui impactent
nos vies. Faut savoir que l'informatique
les les technologies de l'information et
la sécurité qui va avec maintenant
concerne nos vies quand on va à
l'hôpital quand on déclare nos impôts.
Bref dans les moindres faites et gestes
euh et ça c'est important de le savoir.
Donc nous avons des hommes politiques
qui ne comprennent plus la technologie
si tent qu'il l' jamais comprise un
jour. Alors c'est pas gênant dans
l'absolu parce qu'on peut pas être
spécialiste en tout. Ça veut dire que
comme c'est le cas dans certains pays,
je pense en particulier à l'Allemagne
qui a su effectivement capitaliser sur
sa sa communauté de vainqueur, ça veut
dire qu'il faut être bien entouré, il
faut avoir des conseillers euh qui
effectivement ont un sens de l'état et
je pense que depuis le général de
Gaulle, ce sens s'est beaucoup perdu. On
a des lobbyistes. Alors, je suis désolé,
le lobbyiste, le lobbying est un terme
est un terme, on va dire politiquement
correct. En Afrique, on appelle souvent
de la corruption. Euh, il faut quand
même quand on voit comment certains
marchés publics notamment récemment été
violés euh
bon après c'est un problème de
sémantique, on peut on peut dire, mais
ça quand même ça ressemble à ce que l'on
critique chez d'autres. Le problème
effectivement, je crois qu'il faut
revenir à une certaine idée de l'État, à
une certaine intégrité et indépendance,
une certaine force de caractère pour que
nos hommes politiques soient entourés
des bons conseillers. Alors, ça touche
un autre aspect, c'est la sélection de
nos élites. Euh le problème, c'est qu'on
ne peut pas représenter l'ensemble de la
nation uniquement avec une petite
fraction sortie seulement de quelques
écoles. Euh le retard qu'à la France
comparé par exemple à l'Allemagne qui de
ce point de vue-là a été très
pragmatique, c'est que la France est en
train de se couper de toute une fraction
importante de la population d'une
extrêmement grande qualité qu'on a
coutume d'appeler les hackurs. Alors en
France, le problème c'est que le mot
hackur est diabolisé. On oublie
simplement que ce sont des gens qui
privilégient les résultats sur les
méthodes et qui sont capables de gagner
une connaissance intime d'un système. Ce
sont pas du tout les acteurs
malveillants qu'on veut que l'on que
l'on décrit. Ils font d'ailleurs souvent
avec le mot pirate. Ce qui veut dire que
ces gens-là sont diabolisés, sont
complètement écartés du débat alors
qu'ils pourraient contribuer. On parle
beaucoup de réserves citoyennes, mais si
c'est pour le faire uniquement avec des
polytechniciens, des Normals, des
centraliens, on va pas aller très loin.
Je pense qu'il faut toutes les bonnes
volontés sont à prendre. Il faut plus
regarder chez un jeune ce qu'il peut
apporter à l'État et non pas ce qu'il a
fait entre 20 et 24 ans. Et là, je suis
sûr que la France sera un pays qui
redeviendra une nation de tout premier
plan. Il faut quand même oublier qu'il y
a un génie français et pas seulement en
sortie de nos grandes écoles. Moi, j'ai
coutume de dire à mes étudiants que on
est un mélange subtil et aussi un peu
aberrant de d'écart et d'esprit gaulois.
Euh, on le voit dans la communauté des
hackeurs français. On a la chance en
France d'avoir une communauté très vive,
très innovante. Malheureusement une
bonne partie d'entre elles part aux
États-Unis. Faut même savoir que
beaucoup de hackers, qu'il soit Junior
Security Hackur ou Senior Security
Hackur chez Google, Microsoft, Apple,
Oracle, Novel sont des Français et ça
c'est quand même dommage.
Vous parlez de Microsoft. Euh qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire sur les
contrats qui ont été passés par la
défense ? on va dire euh qu'il ne il ne
respecte pas franchement disons la règle
en matière de marché public et que c'est
pas la transparence qui a qui a prévalu.
Mais je veux dire là maintenant tous les
documents ont été publiés et qui
prouvent qu'effectivement il y a
peut-être un certain ménage et certaines
pratiques euh je veux dire à euh à à
revoir. Maintenant il faut savoir que la
France a fait le choix de revenir de
manière très très importante et totale
dans l'OTAN. l'OTAN impose ses règles et
quand je dis il impose ses règles,
impose surtout les produits américains.
Donc c'est très délicat pour nos hommes
politiques et malheureusement nous
n'avons plus de général de Gaul depuis
très longtemps. Euh c'est très délicat
euh de faire marche arrière en tout cas
de réaffirmer une certaine souveraineté
mais en tout cas on n'aura pas de
sécurité si on ne passe pas par ça.
Vous parlez de certaines pratiques lors
du passage de certains contrats avec la
défense. Est-ce que vous pouvez
développer ?
Disons que le lobbying et disons des
règles particulières
s'appliquent alors que le marché le
marché public
les règles du marché public devraient
s'appliquer. On a vu tous les documents,
on a vu qu'effectivement c'était pas la
transparence. En particulier en France,
il y a une obligation quand vous passez
un marché euh c'est de toujours euh
prendre en priorité l'offre logiciel
libre quand elle quand elle est
présente, quand elle se présente. Encore
faut-il la susciter. Or, dans le cas
présent, euh
lors du passage du marché, on n'a pas on
s'est pas assuré qu'il y aurait des gens
venant du logiciel libre qui pourraient
proposer une alternative.
Que sont devenues ces personnes qui ont
signé ces contrats avec Microsoft ?
Alors, on va élargir un peu le débat,
mais en France, il y a une règle qui
veut que tout haut fonctionnaire,
militaire ou non, quand il quitte
l'administration a obligation de ne pas
travailler pendant 5 ans dans
l'entreprise avec laquelle il a
travaillé étant fonctionnaire.
Je laisserai les les personnes qui
regardent cette vidéo faire une petite
recherche et regarder où vont certains
de nos fonctionnaires, par qui sont
recrutés et on verra que c'est une règle
qui est malheureusement régulièrement
baffée.
Le devoir de réserve
al plus que le dévoir de réserve. Le
dévoir de réserve s'applique quand on
est en poste.
Donc le délai de 40
c'est ce que dans c'est un délai de
carence. ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
délai où on va dire je sais pas si c'est
une clause de non concurrence ou en fait
il y a obligation de ne pas travailler
dans un domaine ou avec dans une société
avec lequelle on a passé des contrats.
Très bien. Un dernier mot, qu'est-ce que
vous nous Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire votre votre perception sur les
whistle blowers ? Julian Assange, Jeremy
Amand, Bradley Manings ? Alors, je pense
que bon,
Aon Schwartz,
je pense que ces gens-là ont un rôle
positif. D'un autre côté, ça me dérange
parce que si vous voulez, c'est quand
même le triste spectacle que d'abord, il
faut savoir que l'information vient le
plus souvent euh et d'origine interne.
Alors certes, on pourra toujours dire
que ils ont révélé des choses qu'il
était bon euh alors qu'il était bon, en
tout cas qui intéressait et qui mettait
à jour certains certains faits.
Maintenant, ils l'ont livré de manière
peut-être dans certains cas
irresponsable. En tout cas, ça témoigne
d'une d'un malaise et d'une déliance de
la société.
Vous faites le parallèle avec Vladimir
Vetrof, l'affaire Farwell, ce russe
lassé de cette hiérarchie corrompue qui
a fait fuiter des renseignements
français.
Sauf que je mettrai pas la même chose,
je le mettrai pas sur le même plan.
Pharaoh l'a fait euh au risque de sa vie
et il l'a fait en sachant qu'il
resterait anonyme. Il l'a fait parce que
je pense que c'était un idéaliste pour
autant que je le sache. Effectivement,
je pense qu'il était c'est quelqu'un qui
effectivement était et peut-être dégoûté
de certaines pratiques ou avait compris
que le monde allait changer. On ne peut
pas nier le fait que pas certains de ces
whistle blowers ont un certain ego et il
est difficile de savoir quelles sont
leurs motivations réelles.
Moi je trouve préoccupant quand même
qu'une société parce que les ware il
peut y en avoir dans les sociétés
françaises. Moi je pense que ça illustre
plus le fait que bah les notions de
loyauté, les notions de fidélité ou
disons c'est une forme de vol. Quand on
prend des données qui ne sont pas à soi,
qu'on les met dans la place publique
sans hors de tout contexte, ça pose
quand même des problèmes. Mais je pense
que c'est le révélateur d'une ferte
qu'on est une société de plus en plus
malade où c'est le règne de l'argent, le
règne de la puissance et voilà, c'est
juste un révélateur. Donc après bah
c'est ce qui a révélé, ce qui a révélé
Snowden, effectivement c'est
intéressant. Maintenant, c'est ça ne
sera pas sans poser les problèmes de
disons de sécurité nationale et
internationale.
Je pense qu'il faudrait peut-être
effectivement mettre en place un certain
nombre de
mécanismes pour que
bah les whistle puissent le faire mais
que ce soit quand même alors je vais pas
dire contrôler parce que le mot
protéger législativement parlant les
whistle blowers.
Oui. Oui. Mais ça existe déjà pour
l'administration fiscale.
C'est un problème de méga là. On
favorise vraiment des gens qui à mon
sens, alors je peux me tromper mais
agissent quand même beaucoup par ego.
Euh agissent de manière assez souvent
irresponsable parce que on oublie que
euh l'affaire Wikileak a quand même jeté
en pâure des noms propres des gens qui
étaient des serviteurs de leur état.
Alors on peut ne pas être d'accord avec
l'État américain, mais ce sont des gens
qui ont eu un idéal et qui servent qui
servent leur patrie et je pense que on a
on n' pas le droit de le faire de cette
manière-là.
Prisme a été précédé par un programme
qui s'appelait Stellar Wind.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez d'un programme
secret qui est capable de faire un
mapping intégral d'une population, d'une
entreprise sur les habitudes de
consommation, les habitudes de
comportement d'une population ? Est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est une
façon que l'État exent par une crise
financière a pu trouver pour prendre la
température de sa population et pouvoir
encadrer de futurs ou de potentiels
mouvements de rébellion ? Vous parlez de
Google là. Google c'est ce qu'il fait.
Je veux dire, il y a des outils comme
collusion qui vont que dès qu'on fait la
moindre recherche, de toute façon, on
est déjà mapé et qu'on reçoit des tas de
trucs. Alors après, il est vrai que il y
a deux tendances intéressantes, c'est
queon se préoccupe beaucoup al on parle
beaucoup du big data, mais ça c'est le
disons le le terme marketing d'un truc
qu'on connaît plus depuis longtemps qui
s'appelle le data mining qui recherche
effectivement des grosses tendances. Ce
qui est effectivement clair et ce qui
est intéressant dans la question, c'est
que ces techniques là s'intéressent
maintenant moins aux grandes tendances
que ce qu'on appelle les signaux
faibles, les signaux précurseurs et en
ce qu'en data mining, on appelle les la
recherche d'outlers. Effectivement euh
alors je serais très étonné que des
projets comme ça n'existent pas
maintenant. Sont-ils secrets sont-ils et
tout ? Enfin, je veux dire je dirais
qu'à la limite n'importe quel décideur
et homme politique, je dirais que s'il
le faisait pas, il serait inconscient et
incompétent. Après, faut voir dans
quelles conditions c'est fait, dans quel
but et autres. Mais il est vrai que ces
techniques-là sont très intéressantes et
d'ailleurs ça décide la collecte
d'énormément de données. On l'a vu,
beaucoup de bouleversements
stratégiques, géostratégiques. On peut
parler des révolutions 2.0, on peut pas
on regarde ce qui se passe dans le
monde. Beaucoup n'ont pas été forcément
prévus peut-être parce que ces plans là
n'étaient pas encore actifs. On
s'aperçoit, alors c'est toujours facile
à postériori de de dire bah si on avait
fait ça et ça, on l'aurait vu. Il est
clair qu'effectivement ça va devenir, si
ce n'est pas déjà le cas, une
orientation technologique de tout très
importante en tout cas de tout premier
plan qui peut se révéler dangereuse.
Après, c'est effectivement si le signal
faible c'est la préparation d'attentats
terroristes, tout le monde se félicitera
qu'on puisse les identifier les
identifier et les et les parer parce que
le citoyen quiconque a une famille veut
être protégé. Si maintenant il s'agit de
d'anticiper des mouvements
contestataires, vous savez euh un
résistant c'est un terroriste qui a pas
réussi hein. Euh dans certains pays, on
appelle résistant l'appel terroriste,
c'est juste un problème de sémantique et
de de référentiel. Euh voilà, c'est pour
l'instant vous savez euh les en Syrie
bah si vous demande à Bacher et Laassad
sont dangereux terroristes. La
perception n'est pas du tout la même.
Est-ce que vous avez une préconisation,
un conseil pour les générations qui nous
écoutent, les générations peut-être
futures de hackur, qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez leur laisser comme conseil ?
Je crois c'est de garder l'esprit ouvert
et l'esprit humble et surtout de
d'essayer de ne pas lutter aussi de ne
pas céder au sirène technologique. On
parle beaucoup de prisme, on oublie une
chose, c'est qu'on a le droit, on a le
pouvoir de ne pas utiliser Facebook, de
ne pas utiliser Google. Il y a des
alternatives. Il y a un très beau site
d'ailleurs qui s'appelle
prisme-break.org
qui pour chaque logiciel et technologie
qui est apparenté à Prisme donne assez
souvent d'ailleurs l'alternative dans le
monde du logiciel libre. Voilà, il faut
simplement que je pense qu'il faut
éduquer les populations et les jeunes
font partie de son font partie des gens
qui éduqueront plus tard quand il faut
qu'ils soient ouverts aux autres. Il
faut s'assurer de transmettre la
connaissance. La connaissance ne peut
pas être une une commerciale
commercialisable et il faut bah tout
simplement exercer son droit de citoyen.
Il y aura on aura soit de la liberté
soit de la sécurité mais on aura pas eu
les
Monsieur Filiol qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de l'exception culturelle ?
Comment ça a été amené ? Est-ce qu'on a
oublié certaines choses dans l'exception
culturelle française ?
Je pense qu'on peut avoir une culture
libre quand on a déjà je dire de la
sécurité et je trouve normal que dans
les accords de libre échange, on n'est
pas inclus à côté des la fameuse
exception culturelle, on n'est pas
inclus prioritairement les produits de
sécurité.
Euh ce que font déjà les États-Unis, il
est interdit aux États-Unis de s'équiper
s'agissant de sécurité de produits non
nationaux violant d'ailleurs par
ailleurs l'ordre les accords de libre
échange. Je pense que ça devrait être
obligatoire de rendre les produits de
sécurité et les technologies de sécurité
une chose essentiellement nationale et
donc de la faire figurer aux listes des
exclusions des accords de libre échange.
[Musique]